hey guys it's justine and in front of me
is one of the brand new
m1 imacs and we are going to unbox it
not only am i going to be unboxing this
one but i'm also going to be unboxing
every single color combination that's
going to be in a separate video so look
out for that one let's start with the
pink one first because that's my
favorite
this is the moment are you ready are you
ready are you ready jenna are you ready
to receive you ready is everybody ready
ready i'm ready i don't even think i
need a knife they make it very easy to
open
i don't even know where to start like
this is so exciting
i'm so excited i might cry this is like
honestly a dream
that i had ever since i was little is
like this right i'm living my dream
right now
not only do we have the imac on the
front but it's also on the back
and this little handle is a nice
complimentary color
to the actual computer
oh oh it says hello oh my goodness
it's so beautiful let me spin this
around for you guys
oh here it is oh my goodness it is so
light it's like i'm holding nothing this
is like a big ipad
whoa this kind of looks like a very
similar color to the air pods max
actually
so this is the pink version but this
looks a little red to me
uh does this look familiar to you the
original
hello
[Music]
look here's like a little pull tab right
here to just
pull
[Music]
this is so light let's see what else is
in the box i like that they match the
keyboard and the mouse and all of the
accessories to
the imac color that you choose look how
pretty this
is whoa check this out
it's the ethernet port inside of the
power brick i hardly ever use ethernet
but now i will just because you're here
whoa this
magnetic charging port is pretty
incredible
i know they weren't calling it magsafe
but i'm just gonna go with magsafe
no way they even have the trackpad look
how pretty here's the new keyboard
with the touch id
that's exciting can't wait to edit this
video on this imac
this is so cool
it's a lightning to usbc this is fashion
wait what about this oh i wonder if
there's anything else
oh there's a mouse i can't believe how
beautiful this is i'm completely redoing
my office
it is gonna be themed i guess it's
already themed in pink so i'm just gonna
go home and put this where it belongs
i do like that they've kind of made this
contrasting color so like the
back of the computers is a darker color
to go with the front which is a very
light
i know people were saying that they
would prefer this to be a darker
bezel around it i like the white
anything else in here
oh yes we have the actual power table
oh my goodness they gave you a sticker
for the front and the back colors
i can almost hide behind it can you see
me
oh this looks very very good so this is
a 24
inch display and the fact that this is
so
thin and light is really impressive so
what's great about the new imac
is the fact that they've been able to
consolidate everything with the m1 chip
the thinness of these imacs is so crazy
it is 11.5 millimeters thin
and less than 10 pounds so i'm gonna
show you guys the comparison of how thin
it is
compared to the ipad air i mean honestly
it's about two ipad airs
two like it's yeah wow wow thin
the display is a 24 inch retina display
it's got a new upgraded camera a new
microphone
the 1080p facetime hd camera has a
larger sensor and it has image signal
processing to give you much better
quality there's a new studio quality 3
mic array with beam forming to help
ignore background noises
85 faster than previous 21 inch imacs
50 faster graphics 3x faster machine
learning
it's got four usbc ports two thunderbolt
and of course this new
power connector which is amazing you can
choose from one of the keyboards that
has touch id
or one that doesn't
so obviously you've seen how beautiful
these computers are but the one thing
that is most impressive is how powerful
they are so i'm gonna be using
this envoy pro fx thunderbolt drive this
is made by owc i'm such a huge fan of
their products they are basically my
main storage solution
for everything i edit directly off of
these drives i use them for backup i'm
gonna do a full video on that another
day but
i have all of my content here that i'm
gonna be editing you can edit five
streams of 4k
and one stream of 8k on here and on my
m1 macbook pro
been editing 8k videos and it's been
running amazing so i cannot wait to test
that out
open up my project i had already started
this it's kind of a rough edit at this
point
this kind of looks like a very similar
color to the airpods max actually
so this is the pink version so this is
all 4k footage
10 bit 422 right off of the sony cameras
and it is running seamless
this is actually a multi-cam timeline so
inside of here i have
two different angles which is great
because i can just go in and choose as
i'm editing
which angle i want so i just can go
through press
one two and it makes editing this video
super quick so i'm a huge fan of the
magic mouse for editing because i do a
lot of scrolling to be able to just
scroll up and down the timeline is
incredibly helpful
so this video is not quite done yet but
the video you're watching is obviously
complete so clearly i did finish the
video so let's check out lightroom i
have some photos here from
camera camp this is oh my gosh this is
over a year and a half ago
so this is actually the launch of the
iphone 11 so
oh look here's tyler tyler we miss you
let's edit this little picture i mean
this is this is running
great these are all raw images as well
up that saturation
give me some vibrance that's a vibe add
a little
vignette oh my goodness do you
want to print this out i will i'm going
to print this out for tyler oh look
there's jenna
jenna that's you with your little name
tag let's give jenna a little
bump there turn those whites down some
of the shadows a little bit
there we go oh look at that you look
great
this is when i dropped my iphone the day
that i got it
i mean look how fast we're scrolling
through all these photos too one of the
things that i also love about having the
m1 chip is we're able to run
iphone and ipad apps simultaneously on
here so it's kind of giving you this
whole new perspective of being able to
use these apps
on your iphone you can really only run
one app at a time but i can open up
multiple apps so if i want to have
something for like different recipes if
i want to have a meditation app open
or if i even want to be doing yoga while
i'm trying to cook and meditate at the
same time with an iphone app i could do
that and so could you so we're gonna
download two different meditation apps
at the same time so this
is an app that is designed for ipad okay
we've got both of our meditation apps
open
i feel like i'm gonna be so centered
after this here we go let's play one
let's play the other done anything like
this before this is a
really straightforward technique and i'm
going to talk you through every step of
the way
but all you need to do right now is to
sit back and relax so make sure
that your body and mind helps you relax
she wanted me to close my eyes
now turn your attention together i can't
breathe
i can't focus what do you want me to do
you want to breathe are you going to
open my eyes you're going to close my
eyes
breathe out uh let's play a video game
so i've been playing this game called
story time i got into this recently
because i was on a flight that i didn't
have wi-fi
and i didn't know what else to do and i
knew that some of the apple arcade games
that i'd already downloaded don't need
an internet connection
which is incredible this was one of the
games that was available i'm on like
level i don't even know like i'm over
100 levels
level 158 another cool thing is you can
also
connect xbox playstation controllers to
this
so you basically can be using this as a
console i already know how to play i've
already done it
so here's the game it's so fun you just
kind of like match colors
[Music]
oh this is really fun with a mouse
okay i lost i'll play that again later
okay so gaming
feels nice this doesn't seem to be like
the most processor intensive game ever
let's
crank these speakers
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
now we need to test out doing a facetime
call would you like me to
would you want to do a face i'm calling
you wanted me to call you call you maybe
hi jenna how's it going i know you were
just in here five seconds ago but it's
really good to hear from you
uh well we've been shooting an imac
unboxing video for two days so you know
my favorite color i like the pink and
the purple and the blue this is um
an all new uh it's a 1080p camera it has
a larger sensor for
you know better lighting which i'm
actually kind of i would be backlit
right now
since this is a new 1080p camera let's
test that out and see
what some of the video footage looks
like
[Music]
obviously it's not 4k but 1080p i mean i
have some youtube friends who upload in
720p and uh
i don't think i want to claim that we're
friends anymore do you remember when i
used to
make my youtube videos using the
eyesight camera yeah on my macbook
yeah in 2007 yep i do actually
and now in 2021 you basically can do
everything right here
you kids don't know how great you have
it back in my day
i love the new power brick that they
have it has an ethernet port which is
nice because
that allows you to have a much cleaner
workspace so that's one less cable that
you'll need if you do use ethernet
so i have my pink ipad air here and i
wanted to see
how well it matches because if you just
can't just in case
you guys have a pink ipad air and you
want to make sure that it's going to
match your pink imac
it's perfect and you know what because
this connects to bluetooth
you could actually use the trackpad and
this mouse and the keyboard
with your ipad air got a lot of stuff
happening back here oh you look so nice
looks good i have already messed up my
workspace
it's kind of like my desk so this mac
obviously is equipped with the m1 chip
it also has 16 gigs of ram
we have a 512 gig solid state drive
which is amazing because i do have this
external drive which is two terabytes
if you do decide to get one of these
computers and you are looking to save
money i always suggest
kind of going a little bit less on the
storage because you can always use
external drives so this does have the
eight cores we have the four performance
and four efficiency
and it is completely specked out with
the 16 gigs of ram i honestly can't say
enough great things about the m1 chip
i've been using it in my macbook pro my
macbook air and the mac mini so now
having this new imac
kind of join the family i'm so excited
about this because it really is an
all-in-one desktop solution
and these colors are amazing and they
will look good in any room i need to
figure out where i'm going to put these
each like in the house which one do you
think will be the kitchen mac
i think this will be breakfast mac this
will be my office mac if you guys have
any suggestions of where i should put
these in my house
let me know and then i have to send them
back so that's sad but until then we'll
give them a nice home
thank you guys so much for watching i
hope you guys enjoyed this video if
there's anything else that you would
like me to test out on this imac
please let me know in the comments below
and of course let me know which color is
your favorite
be sure to subscribe and hit the bell so
you notified when i post a new video and
if you enjoyed this video hit the thumbs
up and i will see you in the next video
you